We're here on a runway because for some reason
Brady has printed out the first 1,000,000
digits of Pi on a continuous mile long piece
of paper which we are going to very carefully
unravel today and go for a tour of a million
digits of Pi.
So here's 3.14159 which - for a fun fact - that's
as far as I've memorised and then it carries
on and you've marked every 10 digits so there's
100,000 marker points so we won't get lost,
we'll always know where we are in Pi. Where's
the Feynman Point? Is that seven hundred and
something?
This the Feynman Point, six 9s, 999999, so
that won't be beaten... there is a string
of seven 3s, but that takes another 710,000
digits, so we'll be nearly three quarters
of the way down the mile of Pi before we find
a longer string of the same digit. And the
first one is in the first two metres. Absolutely
incredible!
BRADY: Do you want these? For that.
HUGH: Bring the staple gun back.
We've just hit 123 yards so we're long past
the familiar bits of Pi. So the whole 3.14159,
that is a long time ago. You'd think anyone
who has memorised Pi, we're now in unfamiliar
territory, apart from one guy. What is the
world record for memorising Pi, so someone
recited over 125 yards of Pi, someone memorised
all the way to here and couldn't be bothered
to remember the next zero.
BRADY: Not even a third.
There is a run here of seven ascending digits,
there it goes, 0456789, that is the first
run of seven-digits that go up. Obviously
we're missing 1, 2 and 3, it would have been
nicer with them, but nowhere in the first
million digits do you get 0 to 9 in order.
HUGH: That's nearly three hours.
BRADY: I found some heavy bases for cones,
I've got them in the back...
We're half a mile from the start, and the
trolley team, are they on the horizon? Okay,
Pi has just got a horizon.
Okay, see that 4 there, it appears every now
and then, square number, kind of fun, but
then from here you go, wait there's no fours...
no four, no four, in fact there's no fours
until there, look at that, 157 digits and
there are no fours for that entire run. They've
just vanished. And that is the longest run
we will have in the first million digits that
has one digit completely missing.
With a million decimal places of Pi each digit
should appear approximately 100,000 time each,
that makes sense, but of course it's not exactly
even, some of them don't even make it. There
are not 100,000 zeroes, zero doesn't make
it. 1 doesn't make it. 6,7,8 all don't make
it. The champion though, is 5. There it is,
that there is the 100,000th 5.
Okay we're four hours into this and we are
nearly at a million digits. So they've been
coming out a rate of a quarter of a million
digits and hour, which is approximately 4,167
digits a minute, and we're almost there.
So you guys have done the hard work, do you
want to wind off the last of it. And a million
digits is there!
There!
Alright so that is, it's one, in case you
are wondering.
So there you go, we have just, I mean I think
a token round of applause.
APPLAUSE
So that is absolutely fantastic, and now the
very quick process of rolling it all back
up again before an aeroplane lands.
BRADY: Believe it or not we printed all million
digits of Pi using about eight millilitres
of ink. There, that's what 8mL looks like.
That's because of HP's clever thermal inkjet
technology combined with some very clever
people here at HSA Systems in Denmark.
To see the whole story of how and why we made
this film, check out the links on the screen
and below in the video description. It also
includes extra footage from our day out on
the runway and more curious stuff about Pi
itself.